والان الى الترند حيث تصدر اسم اذاعه بي
بي سي على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه في
دول عربيه تزامنا مع توقف خدمات بث فيديو
باللغه العربيه اليوم الجمعه بعد 85 عاما
من تقديم خدمتها للمجتمع العربي وعبر رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عن حزنهم لقرار
ايقاف بث الراديو الذي طالما ارتبطت اصوات
مذيعيه بذكريات عالقه في اذهان مجتمعيه
وداعا هنا لندن لهذه العباره تفعل رواد
منصه تويتر مع توقف البث الاذاعي اللي بي
بي سي عربي والتي اخترنا منها تغريده
لحسين العمري قال فيها ونحن نعايش الساعات
الاخيره من بث الاذاعه العريقه قبل التوقف
ووداع طواقمها الواحد تلو الاخر للمستمعين
ينتابنا شيء من الحزن لنهايه افضل اذاعه
اخباريه
ما شكلت جزءا من يومنا واخذت حيزا من
ذكرياتنا هنا لندن وداعا
هلال الباديه قال في جزءا من تغريدته
اليوم في الخامسه مساءا بتوقيت مسقط سوف
لن تدق اجراس ساعه بيج بن الشهيره
ولن نستمع اليها الا فينوستالج الحنين الى
الماضي وداعا بي بي سي وشكرا لقائمه طويله
من التميز والابداع راشد حمد البلوشي ايضا
كتب هنا لندن عباره سوف هذه العباده سوف
تبقى خالده في الاذهان والاذان عباره
تعودنا عليها منذ نعومه اظافرنا كيف سوف
ننسى مشهد الاجداد والاباء وهم يضبطون
موجات تردد الراديو على اذاعه البي بي سي
فشكرا جزيلا من الاعماق على كل ما قدمتوه
من محتوى ثقافي ومعرفه اقل ما يصف هو رائع
فيصل مشوح كتب قائلا هنا لندن عباره سوف
تبقى خالده في الادهان والاذان عباره
تعودنا عليها منذ نعومه اظافرنا هذا كنا
قد قراناه سابقا ولكن هنالك الكثير من
التفاعل مع هنا لندن نقرا اذا الدكتور
فيصل فهد المشوح بعد مسيره غنيه ومثيره
استمرت لاكثر من 80 عاما يتوقف بث اذاعه
بي بي سي عربي تلك الاذاعه التي رغم بعضها
الجغرافي الا انها كانت لنا ملجا للمعلومه
عن احوالنا الداخليه او الخارجيه كانت
بالنسبه لي وجبه يوميه للمعرفه واللغه
العربيه السليمه في زمن كثرت فيه التفاهات